[Music]
hi we're live at the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I run social media for Wolfram
research and I'm here with my co-host hi
I'm Reggie I'm part of the Wolfram
emerging Leaders program we're here with
Josh Knight who is the director manager
of sound and vision here at Wolfram and
she's here to tell us about well from
audio image and video processing yes so
can you tell us a little bit about what
you do at Wolfram I'm the manager of the
team that is currently renamed to sound
and vision so we started with image
processing then we added signal
processing and audio processing the next
big thing is video when we were adding
video we knew that we needed a new name
for the team that's so what is your
day-to-day look like we're wearing the
R&D team so we're basically doing most
of the research and development its
day-to-day it's a lot of programming a
lot of research paper reading looking at
the state-of-the-art algorithms for
doing image processing audio processing
and so forth and we are also looking at
a lot of applications so that we know
the development that we are doing in R&D
is actually at the end that's going to
be useful and to the point
for anyone who is using our stuff very
cool so can you tell me a little bit
about we're doing at the conference a
lot of talks the whole sound and vision
team I think it are doing eight talks
this year and we are all of our teams or
most of our theme is remote including
myself so we were giving tips basically
a family or reunion for us every year in
Champaign as well and on top of that we
are excited every year to see
our customers here in Champaign which is
giving us the best feedback we can get
because they're already using the
functions that we provide to them and
they're always asking for more can you
explain what's new and sound envision
this new video we are talking about
video tomorrow we have talks it's the
beginning of it but we have been working
for it for a very long time
import/export ism has been a very
significant part of it previously we
used to support only two formats avi and
QuickTime we're adding as many formats
as we can so that people can interact
with any video that they may have other
discs and so what I'm showing on the
screen is basically a bullet point that
we have already available in the
upcoming version of Mathematica or it's
gonna be there very soon yeah a sneak
peek exactly so these are the format's
that they're gonna be supporting so as I
said we only had a bi and QuickTime
there are a lot of encoding outs out
there which is hidden underneath the mp4
or MOV that you get any one of them
could have many different and coatings
this is basically just a list that says
almost any encoding out there is going
to be supported and then as far as what
elements can be supported as for any
other format that is supported by the
Wolfram language we typically support
general data formats in this case audio
video video stream are going to be
ejected general data formats or elements
but then as well a lot of metadata like
how long it is what is the dimension of
every frame what's the sample
all you and so forth the cool thing I
want to show is this player which is not
probably going to be the final player
that they're gonna release but it is a
player
[Music]
so this is Mathematica notebook
it's basically having a video player
inside of it it's not the main feature
we don't want to create yet another
video player there's enough of it but we
just want to have enough of a player in
Mathematica notebook so that we when we
are processing analyzing we can actually
see what happened to the audio I'll let
you watch that later
all right video stream is another thing
this is not as exciting as a video
object but it's basically a programmatic
way of doing the same same thing that I
did above so let me make this just a bit
smaller so they can fit everything so if
I start the playback you can see up here
that they have the current position of
the video
[Music]
basically this is gonna allow us the
video stream is gonna allow us to create
our own player or also stream and do any
processing on that stream of frames and
stream of audio buffers that come in
that's going to be directly from the
everything is built in and then the cool
things we can do is that for instance in
this case I'm calling this new function
called video map that is taking image
measurements which we had already in the
system and it's computing mean intensity
for each frame and here I'm just
plotting that mean intensity over time
basic processing is also coming things
like for instance in this example I'm
just calling an image processing
function that reflects from left to
right which is not that amusing but
let's just play the eye it takes a
little bit of time so I just pre
computed that audio just gets partly how
one may want to process and then so this
video apply created this new video file
for that we need an export so yes we do
have export and then upcoming
development there is gonna be a lot of
video editing like trim this video or
trim this part of every video frame and
things like that support video functions
support video object in almost every
image processing operation so that we
can just apply any of those frame by
frame or - frame by - frame and so forth
and support video and all of the audio
functions so that all your tracks can be
processed and so forth these are just
some samples of functions that may be
coming soon no promises this is the most
exciting thing all the audience here at
the conference are asking us about video
I guess this is really the next big
thing from our team so there is a lot
still happening with image and audio yes
main main two things that we have been
trying to accomplish there is to fill
the gap so any utility or small function
that was missing from our set of
functionality we are trying to add that
and then we are trying to make all of
that consistent whenever we are finding
inconsistencies so a lot of that is
happening both in image image and audio
we are also doing I'll talk about that
as well we are also doing a lot of
machine learning integration on for
image all of the neural Nets machine
learning capabilities God developed with
the point in mind that image is going to
be one of the main users of it so it was
never behind but for audio audio content
was introduced later and all of the
integration of machine learning neural
nets with audio came a bit later as well
alright and the first thing in the image
updates I wanted to mention I put it up
so that I don't forget we are having a
image processing MOOC it's an
introduction to image processing it's
very basic it's very intuitive it's not
very long 14 chapters including very
many applications cool nice easy to
follow application examples this is
intended for people who want to have
their first step into image processing
and it's not released yet this is in our
internal websites but I'm guessing
within a couple of weeks it's gonna be
out there available for public there are
also quizzes and things like that that
people can take and then there is
certification and all of that similar to
anything else we have on goal from you
so that's big and exciting talking about
MOOCs and courses we are having a signal
processing course
that is also coming out of our team on
their works as well as and neural nets
which is in very early stages but we
also want to have a very intuitive
informative educational not really
teaching Mathematica or Wolfram language
teaching the concepts using all the
capabilities we have which is very nice
you know a few things I've put in the
notebook I can talk about a lot of
neural net machine learning integration
advancements in there the neural net
repository is being expanded on a daily
weekly basis a lot of image networks is
in there and then we are taking all of
those putting them back whenever we can
as built-in functionalities whether it
is a new function or whether it is a new
option for an existing or a new
parameter for an existing function the
things that I highlight in my notebook
are things like face detection which we
had before upcoming is face alignment
this is useful for when you wanna map
one face to another for doing morphing
or if you want to say add makeup or or
anything like that and do things like
that
along those lines we have also had it we
realized that as we understand images
more we need better ways of showing
content on top of images so our
highlight image is being updated to take
annotations like this is the age of the
estimated age for each face it was
possible before it was just longer piece
of code all your updates basically the
same thing we have a lot of new small
capabilities that are coming but a very
big push for having audio support and
machine learning and neural nets one of
the examples I would like to highlight
is for example this spoken digit data
set that we have on our data repository
and this example is showing how to
classify that
we have a lot of ways of extracting
features from audio for instance here we
are using MF CC which is a very commonly
used feature from audio objects audio
signals and then training a small
network here to do the classification
towards the end this is basically
showing all of those audio signals in a
2d embedding and nicely separates all
the zeros from ones and twos and so
forth this is a very nice classification
of all the audio signals a lot of that
is coming we have put a lot of focus on
speech and speaker analysis which is
very exciting we are hoping we can wrap
that up and move on to some other cool
areas when audios are involved among
those are notable speaker we had notable
person classifier which was taking your
face and trying to understand who does
it look like or who it is same thing for
notable speaker I have some other things
but let's let's do a very quick test
anybody want to be my tester too
okay I'll do it yeah hi we're at the
Wolfram technology conference all right
so Jamie Lynn Spears and let's interpret
and interpret that as a person and get
any magic I don't know her there she's
so you sound like all right I scrolled
past over a few things like speech
interpreter which is along the same
lines we are we had interpreter in the
system before which was giving a
strength which could be USA or the
United States of America or any
variation of the country USA now that
could be a spoken signal that you pass
to a speech interpreter and then it's
being speech recognized and sent back to
interpreter to see what what that
country or whatever that class is here
for instance we have a recording of
Italy we pass it to speech interpreter
the country comes back New York is the
most populous city in the United States
of America here we have a longer speech
which has cities and countries in it so
we pass it to speech cases again at the
speech recognition and pass it passes it
to text cases to see what cities what
countries can be found in that recording
and that same function could be used to
get say interpretations and
probabilities for those recordings and
one other nice thing that is coming we
are still working on it consistent
design is annotations for instance I
have a signal and I'm trying to do to
find all the voice section of that so
and then that audio is being annotated
with that we came farther than things
like that so it's a lot it's it's
developing but all of these little
things and big things are gonna come
together in order to solve big exciting
projects
[Music]
you